How did you specify the state, David?
>> So, earlier when we were
talking about our goal state,
we had specified that we wanted
our ceiling to be painted.
And we wrote that as Painted (Ceiling).
So if in this state
the ceiling is painted,
I'll write that as Painted (Ceiling).
Earlier in the initial state,
we said that the robot was on the floor.
And now we know that
the robot is on the ladder.
So I'm going to say Robot On Ladder.
And this is an and, so I'm going to join
them with a conjunction right there.
I wasn't giving any other
information about the world, so
I'm not including anything
else in this state.
>> That's good, David.
In general, if there is information
about the initial state,
additional information for
example dry ladder and dry ceiling, then
those associations about the world can
be propagated to the subsequent states,
provided that no operator in
the middle of this initial state and
this state actually negates or
deletes any of those assertions.
We'll see more of this in just a minute.